hello and welcome to the game highlights
for a game for in the google deepmind
challenge today Lisa Dahl was looking
for the weakness in alphago which he had
not been able to find in the first three
games today
he found it Michael show us how yeah Wow
well so we begin a little yes sir point
alphago is black yes
at this point it's exactly the same
opening as it played in the second game
and at this point Lisa doh change
tactics in the fruit and the second game
being played here and alphago actually
left that so this was actually a kind of
a surprise because just about everyone
was expecting alphago to be sort of
orthodox in its opening and so when in
that game alphago left it and played on
the on this side here so Lisa told
apparently didn't like that and so he
changed his move here top players also
people tend to like to change their
moves mm-hmm just to avoid the same game
for one thing and maybe he thought that
it was important for him to keep
alpha-alpha go on the defensive a little
bit because this sort of threatens to
tack these stones so black a sort of
needs to play that extension and gives
Lee SEDOL the chance to play with a card
very common position here locally
there's a lot of moves that y can choose
from basically any move directly
protecting this one stone will allow
black to play towards the right side
here and make a framework here while
letting white lit that would be also at
joseki but since black does have this
weak stone here it sort of makes sense
for white to switch to the side here and
allow back to take the corner
and create a white week blackroot and i
black played once here this is really
big in helping blacks framework white
played the final you could call that the
final big point or final Oba then what
this was an interesting little
interesting move it's not unheard of
it's a move that has been played before
and there after I pointed played here
black would have been satisfied and play
forcing moves from outside sort of
forcing white to put put a lot of stones
in that corner so this was the plan so
white says no you can't do that now
blacks aim is to try to get some aji
into the corner like this moves like
this which can cause some trouble in the
corner but it's interesting that the
four black does that
alphago plays once here an attempt to
sort of erase the side first and then go
back there later and I don't really know
why I think Lee SEDOL might have been
worried that at this at this point in
time now alphago would be trying
something in the corner I'm not really
clear as to how that would turn out but
normally I think quite should've been
playing one push at least and hopefully
if black plays here then it would be a
different story when my place here there
would be more more space for this why
sure in the actual game white played
here immediately and this does sort of
make quite a bit cramped so this is
something that I didn't really like
forget notice and I thought it was fit
difficult in this fight both the black
group and the white group are actually
weak groups and if you look at the
positions on the side we can see that it
looks like it for instance if white
plays here if we just look at this
position black swoop is the weaker one
but there is the fact that now it's
blacks moves so black gets the K say
play the the key move here that's a kind
of a vital point in white shape and so
because of that the strength of the two
groups is maybe about the same there's
also the fact that if black can curl
around on the top here there's going to
be a big moil in this area okay
so white decided to play the safe move
we can see alphago playing very
aggressively here pushing just closing
off the center and then connecting this
is sort of a vital point white shape
when this move white has a living shape
and so far white is taking territory
here here here and a framework here
which is not really so big mm-hmm
black this is not really territory Black
has territory in the corner maybe here
and then this framework so what happens
to this framework is really important in
this game it's why Stern white played
here and so white started by invading
the side here but decided that was a bit
heavy to actually be moving out with
these stones so he played a very light
move here this is sort of moving out not
really trying to save all of the stones
but also looking at the cutting room and
this cut came later in the game but this
is always something that white is sort
of hoping to play at some point okay
there's a similar to the magic move in
game 2 and 2:30 set although that of
course was this is more of a normal
shoulder hair it's a more normal
shoulder hit in this case actually black
is trying to sort of cover up on the top
and surround these stones how white
handles it so in that way it also
resembles a move that Lee SEDOL played
in game number 3 in which case he was
attaching against a white structure in
the lower right actually an attempt to
attack white center group so it's a this
is basically an attack oblique attack
against white stones here and instead of
trying to take territory over the side
which would sort of sort of fall into
Blackstrap white does have to push
through here and try to make a
connection with these two rules again
just like here alphago is playing very
strongly so quite a similar shape
actually at this point white does have a
kind of a connection if white head for
instance played something like this yet
it would have been much more peaceful
black would probably just take the one
stone
and black would have some thickness
towards here would still have the torna
turret or in this territory and would
later have a move here to cut this off
so why we would need to put one more
stone in for instance here and this the
kind of clumsy shape here is what Lisa
Dole didn't like I said because he also
has a weak point here so the whole group
here although it's connected and saved
now it's still not a very happy shape
and and the fact that black is thick
here it means that blacks can get some
extra points in the center right so
that's why at least it'll just didn't
like that I suppose you can and since
the latter is good for white so he
escaped here mm-hmm
the drawback is that this move is
attacking white here it turns into a
kind of a trade now at this point you
were feeling pretty good for alphago or
alphago right I think alphago should
have a lead at this point and it all
depends on how much white can get out of
the ADI here because there's a lot of OG
or potential especially for this stone
and this stone and the weakness in the
cut and the hunter here I'm just putting
a lot of stones down this this really
puts these terms into so there's a lot
of there's a little bit of potential
here and even professionals when playing
will not be really sure whether this
stone is completely dead or not okay but
for the time being
covering here is a very strong move for
black why can't really allow that to
happen
so white had to put a stone in here
black played here this is a large scale
now if this move happened to be it
turned out that white managed to destroy
this black semi territory with a
brilliant sequence mm-hmm and if that is
true if that if that worked actually
maybe black should have been a bit more
cautious here this would be maybe a bit
over cautious but at least something
like this to avoid that kind of thing I
say but um my theory here is that the
moves that Lee SEDOL did to break up
this center they took me by surprise I
wouldn't be surprised
they were sort of outside the tree of
variations that alphago was creating
because it was a brilliant sequence
which is really amazing though because
and we'll see there shortly but I mean
alphago perform virtually flawlessly in
the first three games yes and then this
game also I think alphago is playing a
good game again yes okay
so suddenly well the moment Lisa doll
sort of it's a pretty standard this is
normal
yeah I'm glad later you're special here
this is another of well there's a choice
here between this move in this move they
both have their drawbacks the whole
place the situation here this black
group has some damage Marie or lack of
liberties
there's weak points and black all over
the place so it is a kind of a worrying
situation however black plays black this
looked like it was a safe move to me to
LuAnn when black played it black white
cuts here again playing Atari and
allowing white to get some stones lined
up here would set up this move right and
that would be a disaster as like the
collapses coming this side would allow
this vicente and what would be again
would be able to use this kind of OG to
run out with really good shape and that
would put these stones in trouble so
this is the move that comes to mind ice
it's a nice thing now white plays here
and this is this is forcing quite black
has answered this and in order to make
this cut work why it really needs he
needs this move this is a forcing move
that obviously will work it might blacks
can answer it white needs this forcing
move and it still doesn't work because
white cuts black comes out here and what
can come here to capture the to stone
right so white needs one more forcing
move here right now if we do this in
order it's just not going to work
because white black can answer the final
forcing move with this this move right
and white cannot get out here
just doesn't work so the move that Lisa
told played was just brilliant and it
was he wouldn't have been playing this
way to start with if he hadn't been sort
of feeling the potential for this move
already
I don't know if you had it completely
read out or maybe just was sort of
smelling something that happened and he
was speak very modest about it in the
press kind of press conference but all
of this stuff he is doing would be sort
of meaningless if he hadn't had
something like this in mind when he did
this was a brilliant move I think it got
a WoW out of me well given the
commentary did basically it's as if
black plays here it means that white
will get that extra forcing move here
and this would set up the capture here
of the blue to black stones not really
paying very much for it capturing these
two two stones would give white a
victory in acts while the black played
here white Plus through here black
covered and white cut now at this point
is still not clear what's going to
happen if black takes the one stone why
you can force with this and force with
this and again why it's got the three
forcing moves that he needed so white
can cut here and capture to surprise
right so it's these three points that
white needs to make this cut work so
that's that's relatively simple in the
actual game alphago stopped playing in
this facility at this point now the move
that I was looking at was this one and
if white plays here it's not going to
work because white cannot capture this
stone and router so this looks bad for
white but there is potential on this
side for instance if white plays here
and black plays here white can push
through here black covers white cuts
and now white plays here after this the
throw in here which kills these stumps
tonight and the cut there well whether
you're right this is bad - yeah so this
would capture these stumps here very
nice so this would be a disaster I'm not
really clear what happens if black plays
this move on this side in which case it
doesn't really seem to work I'm mad but
in actuality alphago apparently decided
that didn't work to play here and so
alphago started doing stuff like this
which is and just didn't work just
doesn't work right after this actually
the game sort of deteriorated for
alphago because alphago was just doing
all sorts of things that did not work
and now took here yeah right and then
played down here and white just took
black played the key point but black was
already losing the sim right here this
whole sequence it didn't black gain some
back on here but it increased White's
territory here really wasted the black
potential there and in the center again
this point and cutting off the two
stones is me I so at this point the game
is already looking good for whites
amazing turnaround for least at all who
had you know basically we had counted we
counted you know 80 90 a hundred points
without anything like this the game
would have been hopeless for right and
this was really a brilliant moved it was
led up to by a sequence here in which
Lisa Oh was certainly sensing something
there in the middle of blacks territory
well thank you for it was it was so long
it seems like a really long commentary I
get another long complicated game thanks
for leading us through it
congratulations to Lisa doll for finally
finding a weakness in a program that up
until now has been Virgil easel seemed
invincible but it's got a bit of a bit
of a flaw so we will look forward to
Game five the final game with great
anticipation
thank you again Michael thank you